bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
diffusion sur les chaînes de télévision
américaines de la déposition du
président bill clinton concernant ses
rapports avec une cabine ski quatre
heures de questions réponses acharnée au
bangladesh 20 millions de personnes
victimes des inondations attendent les
secours internationaux aux famines
épidémies que je près d'un cinquième de
la population forte baisse sur les
marchés boursiers européens plusieurs
cotation était suspendue la bourse de
paris a perdu 3 5% celle de new york est
à la baisse également annie journée
journée mondiale d'information sur la
maladie d'alzheimer le nombre de
personnes atteintes est en forte
progression difficultés pour les
familles qui souhaitent garder un
domicile à domicile un parent malade
exemple avec un reportage et puis la
rétrospective du peintre pierre
alechinsky à la galerie du jeu de paume
à paris 50 ans de peinture célébrer avec
cette rétrospective
aux etats unis plusieurs chaînes de
télévision ont commencé en tout début
d'après-midi la diffusion du témoignage
du président bill clinton sur sa
relation avec monica levinsky quatre
heures de vidéos qui avait été
enregistré le 17 août à la maison
blanche à huit clos le procureur quelle
star devant un jury populaire avait
interrogé le président des états unis
sur tous les détails même les plus
intimes les plus impudique afin
d'obtenir la démonstration que bill
clinton avait menti
la diffusion de cet enregistrement s'est
accompagné la distribution de milliers
de copies des 2810 page d'index au
rapport du procureur kenneth starr une
véritable entreprise pour obtenir la
destitution du chef de l'état comme le
demande de nombreux parlementaires
républicains aujourd'hui nous avons
choisi quelques éléments de cette
déposition vidéo pour tenter de
comprendre comment la vie politique et
médiatique américaine en est arrivé là
commentaire je marque il use
un président des états unis
inhabituellement tendu en train de
décliner son identité comme un simple
citoyen au moment de la prestation de
serment
un président des états unis livide
contraints d'écouter lecture du code
criminel comme un vulgaire prévenu des
images fixes un son médiocre
ces quatre heures et demie de déposition
le 17 août dernier devait rester
confidentielle comme c'est la loi mais
la commission des affaires judiciaires
du congrès dominé par ses adversaires
républicains a choisi vendredi de tout
mettre sur la place publique
pourtant par égard pour la fonction
présidentielle
la comparution vidéo avait eu lieu non
au tribunal mais à la maison blanche
face au président une caméra et trois de
ses avocats et à sa droite le procureur
star et ses quatre adjoints
on l'avait même prévu un faisceau codé
top secret pour diffuser les réponses
présidentielle exclusivement vers les
jurés cantonné au tribunal fédéral
pas de révélations aujourd'hui donc mais
désormais l'humiliation et public
d'abord à la diffusion de la déclaration
que bill clinton sortira de sa poche
pour reconnaître qu est la bienvenue
avec monica lewinsky site et comme
j'étais seule l'asie lewinsky jeudi
m'est arrivé parfois en 96 et une fois
début 90 est d'avoir une conduite
répréhensible
les rencontres n'ont pas comporter de
rapports sexuels ne constitué pas de
relation sexuelle au sens juridique où
je l'entends
mais à trop porter bien des contacts
intimes déplacer une réponse qui ne
satisfera pas ces inquisiteurs tour à
tour précis évasif ont manifestement
révolte et bill clinton devra répéter
qu'au sens je cite où l'entendent la
plupart des américains
il n'y a pas eu rapport sexuel mais
seulement des attouchements au long de
la dignité de sa personne de sa famille
et de ses fonctions il refusera de leurs
en dire plus
d'une certaine manière vous jouez avec
ce qu'il ya de plus mystérieux dans la
condition humaine
hier sur internet aujourd'hui en vidéo
non pas la vérité rien que la vérité
mais une partie de la vérité sur la vie
privée d'un président avant de juger le
congrès américain aura rue damman choisi
de renvoyer la balle sur l'opinion
publique et les sondages
un pari à double tranchant jean marie
losier n'diaye a pas de révélation donc
dans cette diffusion vidéo puisque les
médias américains très fortement
mobilisés avaient déjà tout raconter
trois grandes chaînes de télé nbc nbc et
cbs ont diffusé la première de cet
enregistrement sans la moindre
interruption publicitaire ce qui était
symbolique aux états unis nous sommes
rendus dans les locaux de six billets
cet après midi pendant la diffusion du
témoignage de bill clinton
voyez le reportage de notre
correspondant philippe gassot tout au
long du scandale clinton la grande
presse américaine a été plus qu un
aiguillon elle a souvent au nom du droit
à l'information défendu les valeurs
morales et rien d'autre c'est
particulièrement sensible à la
télévision la presse suit la sphère
minute par minute depuis plus de huit
mois et ça n'est pas fini
les enregistrements du président diffusé
sur six billets ce trouble bon nombre de
confrères mais difficile de trouver
quelqu'un qui partage avec vous ses
états d'âme jobs jobs mon travail ça
n'est pas de juger si les grands
événements doivent être relayées ou non
mon travail c'est de faire ce que
d'autres ont eu pour mission de juger
s'il s'agit d'une information valable
pas facile de parler devant un étranger
de ses doutes quand dans les médias le
mieux partagé c'est la bonne conscience
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait possibilité
de contourner sans danger cela soit
parce que c'est de l'information dont
les gens parlent et nous devons le faire
personnellement je suis troublé qu'on
ait pu aller si loin
aujourd'hui les journalistes font un
drôle de travail demain l'opinion va
réagir et l'audience sera mesurée pour
éviter de choquer les américains et
peut-être être montrés du doigt si ps a
opté pour un décalage de 30 secondes sur
le direct afin de pouvoir couper les
mots trop indécent utilisé pour la
première fois un document vidéo destinée
à la justice pour confondre un président
cela laissera sans doute un malaise
durable avec et saab
je pense que c'est triste d'avoir à
faire ça ce n'est pas quelque chose
qu'on a envie de faire mais c'est un
processus qui a été mise en place par le
congrès américain
si la diffusion des bandes vidéo
entraîné pour bill clinton une baisse
dans les sondages donc sa perte
une partie de l'opinion pourrait bien
aux prochaines élections se retourner
contre les républicains qui aurait eu
pour effet de ramener aux etats unis une
société politiquement correct que l'on
croyait en voie de disparition
et comme s'il ignorait superbement ce
qui se passait sur les chaînes de
télévision le président clinton se
trouvaient aujourd'hui à new york au
siège de l'onu devant l'assemblée
générale des nations unies de nombreux
chefs d'état dont nelson mandela ont
tenu à lui manifester un soutien très
vite ils ont longuement applaudi
monsieur qui tourne sur clinton qui
était venue évoquer le dossier du
terrorisme international
dominique derda nous attendent
en direct de new york alors tout
simplement il a voulu montrer qu'il
continuait son travail
oui absolument vous savez toute la
stratégie de bill clinton et on l'a vu
depuis à peu près un mois consiste à
dire écoutez j'ai commis une erreur
je me suis excusé et maintenant laissez
moi retourner travailler c'est
exactement ce qu'il a fait ici tout à
l'heure en lançant un appel pour une
vaste coopération internationale en
matière de lutte contre le terrorisme
il fait comme il dit son métier de
président et c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'ils
attendent de lui une grande majorité les
américains ils attendent de lui qu'il
soit là qu'il soit présent sur les
dossiers même si personne ne doute qu
effectivement le scandale et la perle et
vince qui pèsent de tout leur poids sur
la maison blanche et paralysent une
bonne partie des actions que bill
clinton pourrait entreprendre
alors dominique est ce que d'après nous
c'est suffisant pour maintenir une
opinion publique favorable et pour
retourner les parlementaires du congrès
n'ont sans doute pas vous savez les les
adversaires républicains de bwin
en offrant en pâture à l'opinion
publique ces quatre heures
d'enregistrement du témoignage de bill
clinton devant le grand jury ont manié
la une arme à double tranchant ils ont
manié sans beaucoup de finesse parce
qu'ils espèrent évidemment que les demi
vérités de bill clinton sa définition
très personnelle de ce que sont des
rapports sexuels il espère évidemment
faire chuter bill clinton dans les
sondages mais ça pourrait aussi se
retourner contre eux car bon nombre de
téléspectateurs pourraient tout à fait
jugé que ces questions qui sont toujours
en dessous de la ceinture
ces questions et bien elles vont trop
loin et cela pourrait rendre bill
clinton plutôt sympathique aux yeux de
pas mal de téléspectateurs il est
maintenant évidemment un peu trop tôt
pour en juger
il faudra attendre quelques jours et
sans doute les élections de novembre les
élections législatives pour voir qu'elle
a été l'un si dense concrètes sur le
vote des électeurs de cette affaire
merci dominique et c'est peu de dire
qu'en dehors des états unis
les réactions des hommes politiques sont
très défavorables la procédure de
monsieur k nester et au rôle des médias
américains en allemagne monsieur cole
s'est dit écoeuré
il s'est dit même ce soir inquiète de la
mise en pièces du poste le plus
important du monde en italie l'ancien
président monsieur cossiga part d'un
lynchage politique et morale et monsieur
jospin interrogé ce matin estimait qu'il
fallait garder le sens du respect dû à
chaque monsieur robert badinter bonsoir
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment qu aux
etats unis c'est une sorte de défaite
judiciaire que à laquelle on peut
assister éviter j'ai regardé par maman
cnn et je peux vous dire que ce que j'ai
vu est honteux honteux humainement par
les questions qu'on a posés à cet homme
n'importe quel homme se serait outragé
par ce type de questions et dans
n'importe quelle juridiction
on aurait prononcé le huis clos je suis
vu pris le passage là par hasard où on
l'interrogent sur les déclarations
balembitz qui croyez moi toute
juridiction ray déclaré le huis clos à
cet instant là et je rappelle que si
bill clinton a accepté de témoigner
c'est parce qu'ils se trouvaient
garantie par le secret des dépositions
devant le grand jury
résultat il a déposé dit on avec toutes
les précautions à ce moment là pour
assurer lé secret monsieur star a fait
son rapport
il a été diffusé sur internet après
avoir été d'ailleurs est écrit par un
journal spécialisé de playboy et
maintenant l'amérique en tirait bien au
delà de l'amérique entière le monde
entier aura entendu ces questions aura
vu bill clinton dans cette situation
c'est honteux vraiment et pour lui et je
dois le dire pour la justice des états
unis je le déplore
totalement et je réprouve complètement
de ce type de procédure c'est vrai que
c'est un lynchage médiatique
c'est vrai aussi qu'on voit maintenant
commencer récupérée et utilisée
politiquement il n'y a plus rien de
judiciaire là dedans merci monsieur
badinter on trouvera tout à l'heure dans
l'émission mots croisés avec art et de
chameau et alain duhamel nous permettait
un mais je voudrais puisque j'en ai
l'occasion je m
à cet instant combien en regardant bill
clinton
génial à mme clinton
combien je me disais que si il n'y avait
pas eu ce comportement cette maîtrise
cette retenue
ce caractère de madame clinton clinton
lui serait perdu c'est d'une façon tout
à fait extraordinaire là la
démonstration de ce que peut être un
couple et si ce couple tiens et si comme
je le disait bill clinton survie
politiquement il le devra pas une très
grande part hillary clinton
car sans son recours et sa présence aux
yeux des américaines il serait
maintenant perdu donc il serait
politiquement mort merci monsieur on
retrouve tout à l'heure à 22h30
il y aura notamment le jus dipietro
l'italien le sluc avait lancé
l'opération mani pulite et dans
l'émission d'arlette chabot et d'alain
duhamel en afghanistan à kaboul les
opposants au régime des talibans
multiplient les tirs de missiles sur la
capitale il y aurait plusieurs dizaines
de morts et des centaines de blessés
parmi la population civile
ces attaques seraient menées par les
forces du commandant massoud n'est celui
ci a démenti ce soir au bangladesh le
gouvernement a demandé au fonds
monétaire international un prêt de 200
millions de dollars pour aider à réparer
les dégâts causés par les inondations
deux mois d'inondations
les trois quarts du pays sous les eaux
un nid
moore est sans doute 20 millions de
personnes sans abri les bateaux chargés
de ravitaillement céréales notamment
arrivent peu à peu mais c'est la
situation sanitaire qui inquiète le plus
le gouvernement de dacca la capitale du
bangladesh
des épidémies combinée à des situations
de famine menace des millions de
personnes
reportage au bangladesh de nos envoyés
spéciaux joy d'énergie et jean-philippe
izel après deux mois d'inondations la
décrue est enfin amorcé aujourd'hui
encore les deux tiers du pays sont sous
l'eau
le bangladesh pays pourtant habitué aux
grandes crues des fleuves comme le gange
ou encore le brahmapoutre n'avait jamais
connu pareille catastrophe le bilan est
très lourd
plus de 20 millions de personnes souvent
totalement isolé attendent
quotidiennement les secours à shanghai
pour la première fois trois tonnes de
blé et 800 litres d'eau potable vont
enfin parvenir aux villageois dont les
rivières ont été détruites
malgré quelques rues encore inondé d'un
capital de 9 millions d'habitants a
évité le pire protégée par des digues
qui n'ont pas cédé
dans tous les quartiers la solidarité
envers les sinistrés s'organisent
entreprises partis politiques
associations locales fabrique nuitées
jour des cas pâti ces galettes de farine
qui dans l'urgence fourniront les
calories nécessaires pour survivre dans
cette association
les bénévoles fabrique 15000 qui a pâti
par jour les gens de notre quartier sont
formidables que nous amène de la farine
de l'eau les disques alain parfois même
un peu d'argent
les zones inondées sont situés de
l'autre côté de la digue
le plus difficile pour jamal est de
faire parvenir les cas papilles aux
familles restées depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines sur le toit de leur
maison
ici l'eau est montée jusqu'à six mètres
de haut la plupart des habitants sont
des travailleurs journaliers qui ne
peuvent plus se rendre dans la capitale
leur survie ne dépend que de l'aide
alimentaire fournie par l'association de
diamal je vis très difficilement ses
huit enfants
j'ai plus de travail avec la décrue
d'autres problèmes vont se poser
l'acheminement des secours sera rendue
encore plus difficile et les maladies
liées à la malnutrition vont
inévitablement à paraître
depuis plus d'un mois la plupart des
écoles sont fermées au bangladesh
elles servent de refuge aux milliers de
victimes des inondations qui ont dû fuir
les environs de dacca la capitale
dans cette école plus de 600 personnes
s'entassent dans une promiscuité total
notre santé est très mauvaise il n'y a
aucune hygiène ici moi je deviens seul
l'hôpital spécialisé dans les maladies
infectieuses accueille chaque jour des
nouveaux cas de diarrhée
le nombre de malades est déjà multiplié
par trois depuis quelques jours des
tentes ont dû être installés à
l'extérieur après deux mois
d'inondations qui ont paralysé le pays
les médecins craignent avec la décrue
d'être débordé par le nombre de nouveaux
malades surtout des enfants
premières victimes de la malnutrition il
y aura de plus en plus de maladies
diarrhéiques et le cas de malnutrition
et lorsqu'un enfant souffre de
malnutrition il est exposé aux
infections telles que la diarrhée et la
pneumonie ou le bangladesh produit
essentiellement du riz cette année les
inondations ont détruit 800 mille tonnes
de récoltes prévues
le programme alimentaire mondial
coordonne au mieux l'aide internationale
qui a promis 600 mille tonnes de
céréales
quinze mille tonnes sont déjà arrivés
par bateau c'est maintenant que commence
la période critique parce que ces
populations sont à bout elle non plus
elles n'ont plus les moyens financiers
et donc c'est maintenant qu'il faut
commencer à les soutenir avec une aide
alimentaire
ici on ne parle pas encore de famine
mais le bangladesh attendent toujours
l'aide internationale des nouvelles
plutôt rassurantes pour les habitants
des antilles l'ouragan george accompagné
de pluies très violentes a perdu
cependant beaucoup de sa puissance les
dégâts sont pour l'instant uniquement
matériels
et les autorités civiles et militaires
exprime un certain soulagement notez que
les îles de saint martin saint
barthélémy ont cependant été touché par
ce cyclone en suède à la suite des airs
et des résultats des élections générales
hier les sociaux démocrates alliés aux
ex communistes n'ont pas la majorité
absolue au parlement à stockholm c'est
un échec pour le premier ministre
sortant qui doit composer donc avec les
ex communistes sur les marchés boursiers
les baisses continues de nombreuses
cotation ont été interrompus dans celle
d'alcatel en france la bourse de paris a
perdu 3 5% et aux états unis à wall
street il y avait également une nette
baisse des cotations il y a plusieurs
raisons combiné à cette crise
capitaliste
explications jean bernard schmidt
maîtresses elle qui appelle encore 17
heures la bourse de paris faire c'est le
moment de faire les comptes
dans cette société de bourse parisienne
comme partout ailleurs on a encore vendu
aujourd'hui plus d'action que l'on en a
acheté du coup l'indicé cac 40 termine
en forte baisse -3 54%
c'est dur à vivre des journées aussi
comment j'arrive mandela extrêmement
extrêmement salut c'est un lundi noir
sur les marchés la bourse de paris tombé
à son plus bas niveau depuis le 24
février dernier et elle n'est pas la
seule
la plupart des places financières
européennes ont connu de fortes baisses
la bourse d'amsterdam a même dû fermer
quelques minutes à l'origine de cette
fébrilité les incertitudes persistantes
du côté de la russie de l'asie et de
l'amérique du sud
ajouté aux déboires de bill clinton
il ya de la nervosité le marché a du mal
à anticiper ce qui va se passer
d'où une réaction sans doute plus
particulièrement nerveuse à tout ce qui
peut présenter un risque est aujourd'hui
il y en a eu pas mal parmi les titres
les plus touchées alcatel une fois de
plus en chute de 40 % la semaine
dernière l'action a encore perdu 8%
aujourd'hui son pdg serge sur uc avoue
une erreur de communication mais s'en
prend également au marché dans certains
secteurs des télécommunications de très
grandes entreprises je ne parle plus
alcatel ont perdu en relativement peu de
temps la moitié de leur valeur par
rapport aux plus hauts et des
entreprises donc personne ne met en
doute le futur nom donc il ya une
situation absolument invraisemblable qui
se dessinent sur les marchés financiers
et cette situation pourrait bien durer
d'autant que de plus en plus de grands
groupes européens notamment philips
revoient à la baisse leurs prévisions
pour 98,5 grève dans les services
d'urgence hospitaliers et les samu
aujourd'hui les médecins urgentistes ont
été reçus au ministère de la santé par
bernard kouchner
ses médecins ont souvent un statut
précaire des rémunérations faibles et il
souhaite que l'on rénove ce statut cette
grève était symbolique puisque les
urgences ont été assurés mais ces
grappes voulait éclairer une situation
souvent dramatiques
voyez le reportage de l'hôpital
saint-antoine à paris 2 jan frontier
frédéric de la rue le travail continue
malgré la grève une grève de principe
puisque ces spécialistes de l'urgence
sont assignés à travailler infarctus ou
bras cassés journée ordinaire à
l'hôpital saint-antoine de paris
aujourd'hui encore comme d'habitude les
malades seront plus d'une centaine à
être soigné malgré des conditions de
travail de plus en plus difficile
d'aborder les noms qu'on ne sont pas
adaptés rires que les locaux ne sont pas
adaptés
parfois on est obligé dans l'est des
malades en radio centrale qui tourne qui
sont tous sous sol donc non la 2 etc
soignant la journée il songe et 30 des
chariots
les remontées de les ramener enfin quand
elle montrez-moi marché là juste à la
porte
le manque de moyens se fait cruellement
ressentir alors que les consultations
elle augmente de 5 à 10% chaque année
aujourd'hui les deux à trois mille
médecins d'urgence en france attendent
donc avec impatience une réforme du
système dans son ensemble pour que les
services des urgences distille ne soient
plus les laissés pour compte de
l'hôpital
on prête la douleur on est en première
ligne de la douleur les gens viennent
consulter parce qu'il souffre et c'est
vrai qu'il ya un manque de
reconnaissance des pouvoirs publics
certes mais aussi du corps médical plus
de médecins une filière davantage
reconnus chose promise par bernard
kouchner ce matin les urgentistes
attendent désormais que ces promesses
soient tenues
demain sera présenté le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
1999 mais depuis samedi à l'issue d'une
décision prise par le premier ministre
la réforme des cotisations patronales
c'est à dire la baisse des charges
envisagée pour les plus bas salaires
n'est plus intégrée dans ce projet il
est vrai qu'il ya débat même au sein du
gouvernement en clair si l'on veut
baisser les charges sur les bas salaires
dont il faut compenser par une hausse
des charges sur les salaires des cadres
par exemple ce qui réduirait l'effet
positif sur l'emploi
reportage sébastien libère frédéric
basket
pour les champignons rien ne remplace
encore la main des ouvrières elles sont
170 sur les 250 salariés de sept fermes
industrielles salaire moyen 7800 francs
nets primes et heures supplémentaires
comprises mais les augmentations du smic
cette année et l'an passé n'ont guère
arrangé les affaires de leur patron et
que nous sommes incapables de répercuter
cette hausse sur le prix de vente
pourquoi parce que nous sommes de plus
en plus concurrencé par des pays à bas
salaires et que ces pays proposent des
prix défiant toute concurrence et nous
ne pouvons pas rester avec le taux de
charge que nous vivons actuellement
au total l'entreprise vers cette année
23 millions de francs en salaires et
près de sept autres millions en
cotisations patronales maladie maternité
vieillesse accident une charge jugée
insupportable sur les comptes
la baisse des cotisations sur les bas
salaires est donc considéré ici comme
urgente et salutaire pour rester
compétitif créer des emplois
on espère
pouvoir embaucher alors que pour
l'instant on a plutôt la classe de
devoir débauche s mais pour aider didier
motte
le gouvernement souhaiterait mettre à
contribution les patrons comme sylvain
breuzard à la tête d'une société de
services informatiques en pleine
croissance
les cotisations patronales sur les hauts
salaires pourraient être alourdies
ici le salaire moyen avoisine 17 mille
francs par mois soit on ne compense pas
et donc on réduit nos résultats nos
bénéfices soit on va essayer de
compenser en vendant quelques chaises
cocon persia liste réduire les bénéfices
en partie redistribués aux salariés
c'est risqué de démotiver de précieuses
informaticiens convoité par les
concurrents des concurrents anglais
belges hollandais qui pourrait aussi
profiter d'une hausse des tarifs des
sociétés françaises bref jouer sur les
cotisations patronales entraînerait tant
de complications que le gouvernement
préfère aujourd'hui prendre son temps et
se garde bien de chiffrer le nombre
d'emplois qu'une telle mesure pourrait
créer à bruxelles la commission
juridique du parlement européen a voté
la levée de l'immunité parlementaire du
président du front national monsieur
jean marie le pen les députés européens
lui reprochent des propos révisionnistes
tenue en décembre 97 à toulon à l'issue
du premier tour de l'élection
législative partielle la candidate du
front national notamment sandrine le
chevalier qui a obtenu 30 9,6 pour cent
des voix sera opposé à la socialiste
madame odette casanova qui a recueilli
36 6% des voix le second tour s'annonce
particulièrement serré les électeurs du
candidat de droite mark bell sont pour
l'instant eux laissés libres de leur
choix
il y a eu près de 57 % d'abstention hier
à toulon reportage michaël darmon yann
streiff
toute la journée de dimanche les
électeurs sont arrivés au compte-gouttes
dans les bureaux de vote malgré les
enjeux à toulon l'abstention progresse à
chaque scrutin le premier en pâtir sera
le candidat de l'alliance 21% des voix
la droite varoise est encore éliminés
lors de la dernière élection marque bel
n'était pas candidat il avait cependant
appelé à voter pour la gauche au
deuxième tour cette fois s'il est
beaucoup plus prudent et je suis jeune
candidat investi par l'alliance
c'est donc l'alliance qui va préciser
s'il le souhaite sa position d'autres
n'accepte pas ici de se réfugier
derrière les états-majors et considère
qu'il faut tenir un discours plus clair
pendant le deuxième pour la crise à
droite continue ce qui est une partie de
l'âme des jeunes toulonnais moi je peux
vous dire qu'il n'adhère absolument pas
aux thèses du front national qui est un
parti qui prône l'exclusion et à ce
moment là chacun fort en son âme et
conscience
mais battons nous pour les piliers
fondamentaux de la république
le front national espère exploiter ces
dissonances car malgré sa position en
tête sandrine le chevalier perd des voix
par rapport au dernier scrutin est celle
qui laisse aux familles des monarchistes
se découvre soudain d'autres valeurs
j'avais tous les palio à le rejoindre
dans le rassemblement national pour la
défense le général de gaulle l'europe
des nations
et dans cette course aux électeurs de
droite odette casanova la socialiste a
elle aussi sa petite référence moi c'est
un duel politique entre
les démocrates et les républicains et
une organisations extrémistes racistes
et xénophobes comme le dit le président
de la république
dernier épisode de ce feuilleton
électoral à toulouse dimanche prochain
et encore une fois les abstentionnistes
on la crée du dénouement il faut ajouter
que dans l'autre législative partielle
dans les autres à dunkerque à bord pour
le deuxième tour ce sera un affrontement
ps udf rpr abstention également de 60%
et tassement des voix socialistes à
l'issue de ce premier tour
et puis à aubagne dans les bouches du
rhône c'est le communiste qui est en
tête
il sera opposé au 2e tour dimanche un
candidat de démocratie libérale à paris
3ème audience devant la cour d'assises
du procès de florence rey accusé du
meurtre de trois policiers et d'un
chauffeur de taxi comme il y a quatre
ans on examinait cette après midi les
conditions de la prise d'otages
quand florence rey son ami audry maupin
les témoins ont fait apparaître des
contradictions dans les aveux de
florence rey commentaires dominique
verdeilhan trois semaines
d'hospitalisation deux mois de
rééducation quatre ans d' analyse jacky
bensimon est encore sous le choc
quant à la barre il fait face aux armes
disposés dans une vitrine
il se met à pleurer jacky bensimon
dépeint une florence rey calme
al'inverse d'audry maupin très agitée en
âge prise en otage par le couple jacky
bensimon que l'on voit ici lors de la
reconstitution en neuf ans 95 fonçant r5
vers le bois de vincennes
le témoin est incapable de dire combien
de balles ont été tirées de sa voiture
il y a eu peu de paroles échangées dit
il mais je ne les oublie pas toutes ont
été prononcées par florence rey à audrix
son compagnon à la 10 buts le en parlant
du motard qui les suivaient à l'otage
l'a dit si tu t'arrêtes 7 buts
au moment où on a dit si tu darretche de
but elle n'est pas d'accord elle a dit
qu'elle a jamais dit ça alors ça c'est
c'est un vent table c'est toujours pas
inventé ça mais c'est pas possible
d'oublier ses phrases là si tu t'arrêtes
tu bu c'était c'est ma vie qui était en
jeu donc on peut pas oublier ce à quoi
qui attirait surkis et l'interrogation
du jour plusieurs témoins sont venus
dire qu'ils avaient cru voir leur en
seraient tirées à bout portant sur les
policiers le chauffeur de taxi une
version contredite par les expertises
balistiques des experts qui seront
entendus demain et qui sont pour
l'instant le principal élément à
décharge pour florence rey en moselle
après trois agressions commises en une
semaine par des pirates de la route la
gendarmerie demande aux automobilistes
de ne pas tomber dans la psychose de
très nombreuses patrouilles de
gendarmerie ont été organisés sur les
routes de moselle pour éviter de
nouvelles agressions
ce lundi a été décrété journée
internationale de la maladie d'alzheimer
nous verrons dans quelques instants ce
que signifie pour une famille la vie
auprès d'une personne atteinte par cette
maladie d'alzheimer gens dans la
physique et qu'est ce que c'est que
cette maladie c'est ce que les médecins
appellent une démence dément ce n'est
pas le sens commun l'acception commune
s'agit pas de folie il s'agit d'une
altération progressive d'un certain
nombre de fonctions en particulier des
pertes de mémoire des troubles de la
parole et une difficulté à se mouvoir
je sors de progression de cette maladie
y ait une progression linéaire ya deux
cent cinquante mille cas en france de
malades ya ce genre de 150000 personnes
il ya 92 mille nouveaux cas par an c'est
une maladie qui laisse une espérance de
vie extrêmement réduite et au fur et à
mesure que l'âge augmente le nombre de
cas augmente sa suis vraiment de très
près la courbe des âges
alors peut-on la soigner et avec quoi
actuellement il ya deux médicaments qui
sont soit marché là s'appelle attaque
rime donc le donner et pile ce sont des
données paisible part dans ce sont des
produits qui sont censés améliorer la
mémoire
mais dans les faits c'est puise au bout
de quelques mois ce ne sont donc pas des
médicaments miracles il ya tout un tas
de pistes de prévention alors bien sûr
l'espoir très lointain ce serait la
thérapie génique ça sur les pistes de
recherche mais on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui
qu'il peut y avoir des moyens préventifs
notamment tous les traitements à base
d'hormones d'estrogènes que l'on donne
aux femmes après la ménopause semble
retarder l'entrée dans la maladie
certains traitements qui abaisse la
tension artérielle certains anti
inflammatoire qui pourrait empêcher
là aussi le déclenchement de la maladie
et puis très probablement aussi l'arrêt
du tabac tout ce qui permet aux
vaisseaux sanguins de ne pas être altéré
soit par le pas du dépôt de cholestérol
soit par les effets du tabac merci jean
daniel et vient en france quelques
services spécialisés dans cette maladie
mais de nombreuses familles souhaitent
garder leurs parents à domicile c'était
une prise en charge qui demandent des
investissements financiers importants
mais aussi une très grande disponibilité
nous sommes rendus à l'inde en or voici
une femme angélique qui depuis dix ans
assiste son mari atteint d'alzheimer
reportage marianne masse et dominique
maes
huit heures c'est l'heure de la toilette
au lit
pour andré depuis un an et demi il ne
peut plus marcher c'est angélique sa
femme qui s'occupe de tout avec une
énergie sans faille
donc c'est surtout entre conjoints
robert schuman ap
mais malheureusement les papas les
mamans ils sont plutôt souvent placé
mais c'est un choix dès le début de
garder votre moral
ah oui et mon souhait c'est d'arriver
jusqu'au bout avec lui les premiers
troubles sont apparus il y a dix ans
perte de mémoire fugue
andré a été mis en retraite anticipée
petit à petit les contacts avec sa femme
se sont réduits au seul regard
il coûte je ne sais penser me
reconnaître en tant que sa femme ou en
tant qu'habitué que je lui donne ses
soins je ne sais pas où regarder andré
auprès d'elle angélique a dû transformer
toute sa maison et là c'est un fauteuil
c'est prévu pour l'eau il ne roule pas
donc il est même bien même le siège à
l'ensemble et rire ou donc ce qui nous
permet d'aller chercher dans son lit et
l'amener ici prend sa douche deux fois
par jour c'est la visite de l'infirmière
une aide précieuse pour les gestes du
quotidien devenu très technique
trois corps on peut prendre en charge un
malade comme ça à domicile à condition
que tout le monde y met du sien
on échange des idées on tourne et c'est
toujours d'améliorer les choses pour que
ça aille pour lui pour que ça aille pour
nous pour que ça l'aide elle
bon on essaie de lui remonter le moral
quand il faut ap
il fait peur ces malades n'en font peur
ça a été terrible
il se prend pour coincer les gens eux
mêmes la famille moi j'aime bien avoir
je dois vous des contacts c'est très dur
prévu reproduire alors pour souffler
angélique rejoint une fois par semaine
un groupe d'autres malades pour un repas
où l'on parle on rit on s'entraide
il faut assumer
et avec le avec cora je suis avec le fou
rire le problème aujourd'hui que je paye
vie monotone ont des coups de cafard
jose est assez simple parfois ces deux
tableaux impressionnistes volé ce matin
au musée des beaux arts de nice une
oeuvre de claude monet et une autre
d'alfred sisley ont été dérobés par deux
hommes qui ont pris en otage le
conservateur du musée
les deux tableaux de monet sisley sont
connus répertoriés in sont normalement
par vendable alors pour le plaisir et le
plus sereinement du monde il faut
profiter de l'importante rétrospective
du peintre pierre alechinsky dans les
galeries du jeu de paume paris
c'est une centaine de tableaux c'est à
dire un demi-siècle de la vie et de
l'oeuvre de pierre alechinsky que l'on
peut ainsi découvrir reportage georges
bigot pascal couillaud
ce qui est spontanée n'est pas forcément
réussi et doit être répétée jusqu'à la
satisfaction du regard la proverbe
japonais dit celui qui possède une belle
écriture des styles bien à l'âge de 27
ans à l'échéance qui consacre un film à
la calligraphie japonaise calligraphie
que l'on retrouve tout au long de son
oeuvre
aujourd'hui exposé au japon cet homme a
le goût de lancre il grave dès ses
débuts une série d'os forte des pointes
sèches avec le groupe cobra y êtes à la
recherche de la fraîcheur inspiré du
dessin d'enfant et à l'imprimerie comme
d'autres vont bistrot c'est une passion
qui me vient de très loin
j'ai une excitation à l'odeur de l'anc à
l'arôme de lancre le gaucher contrarié
que je suis à une écriture maladroite
mais il se débrouille dans la main
droite et heureusement on a laissé ma
main gauche pour les menus travaux
autrement dit pour la peinture et le
dessin et j'ai gardé toute la liberté
cette manne a dans les années 50 à
l'échéance qui tente des expériences
subi des influences il se cherche
il peine encore à l'huile sur chevalet
on a à peine le temps dans une vie de
connaître deux ou trois choses qui
peuvent vous convenir et mêmes donc
aussi bien aux débuts de perdre dix ou
quinze ans de sa vie à ne pas avoir
trouvé tout de suite
ce tableau de 1965 central park de new
york vu d'en haut et le point de départ
du style qui a fait sa célébrité
une image central entouré de marge dans
lesquelles il dessine une sorte de
journal intime où se mêlent les choses
vues et les vues imaginaire
à l'échéance qui nous rappellent parfois
ses origines belges les gilles de binche
lui offre un carnaval de couleurs sur
papier à l'acrylique et à l'encré avec
humour et poésie à la chance qui nous
entraîne vers sa voluptueuse et calme
planète
la galerie du jeu de paume à paris on a
appris en fin d'après midi le décès de
la tête américaines florence griffith
joyner foucault championne olympique du
100 m 200 m et relais 4 100 m aux jeux
de séoul elle est également toujours
elle détient toujours le record man pour
record du monde du 100 m et du 200 m dos
maillot jaune c'est fsi n'a donc essayer
de le battre
france défi devenir 39 ans serait morte
d'apoplexie voilà la fin de ce journal
je vous rappelle l'information que nous
avons largement développée au début de
cette édition la déposition de bill
clinton la vidéo qui était diffusé sur
toutes les chaînes de télévision
américaines mobilisation médiatique
critiques très vives à l'étranger de
cette épreuve imposée au président
clinton
on en a tellement perdu monsieur
badinter tout à l'heure en direct dans
ce journal
dire que c'était honteux dans quelques
instants la météo de sophie davant météo
importante car demain c'est une journée
sans voiture dans 35 villes de france 2
n'oubliez pas à 22h32 retrouverez
arlette chabot alain duhamel pour la
première de la rentrée de mots croisés
dont il sera question les pouvoirs des
juges avec juges italiens di pietro de
l'udc a lancé l'opération manipulait les
mains propres et puis robert badinter
notamment à minuit ce sera le dernier
journal qui sera représentée par bruno
roger-petit suis du cercle avec philippe
lefait à 7h50 demain dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde recevra pierre
moscovici
le ministre délégué aux affaires
européennes et à 13h40 esther et rachid
arhab à demain 20h bonsoir merci